non soir gervais vespière merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rtl
c'est vrai que ça fait trois ans que
l'arabie saoudite et le qatar sont en
froid elle pouvez vous nous rappeler
brièvement pourquoi alors vous avez su
lier tout à l'heure à quelques instants
la chronologie des faits effectivement
c'est intéressant de savoir que en 2017
au mois d'avril
donc le président des états unis est en
visite à ryadh au mois de mai à le
prince mohammed bin salman et devient
prince héritier ce qui n était pas
jusqu'à présent et au mois de juin vous
avez la décision contre le qatar donc
convergence ou bien coordination mais
c'est intéressant de voir l'ensemble du
cheminement alors les reproches à
l'époque est effectivement de la
proximité du qatar avec l'iran il faut
savoir que sur le plan économique et
énergétique
l'iran et le qatar partagent le même
gisement géant gazier
ce qui fait du qatar là un des
principaux producteurs de gaz au monde
et bien repose sur un gisement qu'il
partage avec l'iran donc une proximité
et un lien potentiellement tirait de
tension avec les autres pays du golfe
est aussi de savoir que le qatar était
très très proche et est relativement
proche des frères musulmans est proche
donc de la turquie à vous avez évoqué la
présence de soldats américains nombreux
au qatar il y a aussi un petit
contingent turc n'est ce pas un présent
au qatar donc il y à une situation
géopolitique le goal de balle très
intéressant qu'est lesquels l avantage
pour les états unis de rétablir ses
relations on vous l'avait dit une base
militaire au qatar on le sait
notamment pouvoir survoler le territoire
de l'arabie est ce que c'est essentiel
c'est pas les états unis qui sont
vraiment les parties prenantes et ce par
les parties prenantes ce sont les
saoudiens avec l'ensemble des états du
golfe et le qatar a donc les états unis
sont là en tant que médiateur à la
l'amélioration des relations saines
entre les états du golfe et le qatar est
en train de se faire donc à l'intérêt
effectivement c'est une plus grande
distanciation vis-à-vis de la turquie
comme je lai les vienne a évoqué tout à
l'heure deuxièmement de réunir
l'ensemble des états du golfe à après
ces trois ans et demi dre de tension
parce que il est mieux d'être ensemble
pour peut-être avoir une voix au
chapitre des futures négociations avec
l'iran et avec la communauté
internationale concernant le nucléaire
iranien
une question de sécurité aussi le fait
d'être de ramener cette unité est ce que
c'est un atout pour la sécurité dans la
région
il n'y avait pas de tension militaire
l'espagne avait simplement les tensions
je dirais d'ordre et économique et donc
de moindre facilité de circulation pour
les personnes et pour les produits
commerciaux donc il n'y a pas de tension
a vraiment militaire aucunement entre
les les l'ensemble des ses participants
il y à des contreparties évidemment pour
pour le qatar pour revenir dans la
normalité avec ses voisins du golfe
la chaîne al jazeera étaient priés
d'être moins critique envers l'arabie
saoudite ça fait partie des conditions
ça veut dire que la chaîne est juste un
instrument pour pour le pays à agir a
été à une des vitrines et est une des
vitrines du catalan ce pas ce que
j'appelle la différenciation qatari la
différenciation qatari elle s'est fait
effectivement dans la communication
elle s'est faite dans la stratégie du
sport elle s'est fait dans le
positionnement politique de proximité
avec les frères musulmans donc ces
différences à 2
e2 du rôle du qatar ou de la puissance
du qatar devrait être un petit peu
arrondi dans les pays du golfe les plus
critiques envers le qatar il ya les
émirats arabes unis pourquoi je pense
qu'il y a cette rivalité autour de l'
influence des frères musulmans
et donc il est souhaitable effectivement
et je pense que cela va se produire que
le qatar prennent une certaine distance
vis-à-vis des frères musulmans parce que
les frères musulmans ne joue pas à son
ont été toujours très très bien vu par
téhéran et réciproquement
téhéran a toujours bien vu j'avais la
volonté d'introduire des règles
islamiques dans la société à nationales
des pays a donc cette promiscuité entre
téhéran et puis les frères musulmans est
bien à ceux reflétés vis-à-vis du qatar
et le fait que le qatar soit peut-être
en train de s'éloigner un petit peu est
un signe positif
la turquie a appelé à la fin des
sanctions contre le qatar ça devrait
être fait selon vous bah écoutez là la
turquie est complètement observateurs de
ce qu'elle peut dire sur ce sujet là ne
vaut pas grand chose n'a pas un rôle de
puissance elle n'a pas le rôle d'
influence donc ça peut être une demande
pour aider voyez-vous ce que tu
j'évoquais tout à l'heure à savoir son
allié ou son partenaire plus exactement
qatari avec lequel donc elle entretient
des liens
le qatar on s'en souvient a été
transcrit transformé en il par l'arabie
saoudite justement pour l'isoler ils
vont faire machine arrière vous pensez
je pense qu'à partir du moment où vous
dites que les relations s'améliorent et
bien effectivement il faut que à nouveau
aller qatari puissent se rendre dans les
émirats arabes unis se rendre en arabie
saoudite il faut que les produits qu'ils
puissent transiter a depuis les émirats
arabes unis par les ports est bien puis
se rendre aussi à doha donc il y aura
forcément une fluidification de
à des mouvements de personnes et de
marchandises entre le qatar et
l'ensemble des pays du golfe
merci beaucoup gérard vestiaire pour ses
explications très claires de la
situation merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur arte et merci à vous bonne
soirée